jessica is in Ohio hi Jessica welcome to
the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave thank you I
am calling because I am in the middle of
I'm a divorce and I have a toddler and a
six-month-old and right before this
happened we had just got out of baby
step two so I've been in the middle of
baby step three but also I've been
trying to cash flow will your bills and
I know that their court cost fees coming
eventually and I don't really know where
I am
baby I'm sorry and with little babies
how long y'all been married almost 10
years what happened a lot a lot this is
very unexpected okay so where are you
working outside the home already
yeah yeah I have a career of myself
great okay so what do you make about
fifty five thousand okay so you're not
on a baby step you're in the middle of a
hurricane and what you do just push
pause on all this stuff and you pile
cash as high as you can possibly pile it
to cover all of these expenses and
problems that the storm is bringing when
the storm passes then we will rebuild
and start fresh and push play on your
baby steps again but for today food
shelter lights and water clothing for
you and your babies and keep them keep
the lawyer bills moving and the court
costs moving and be done with it so are
their assets as their home that's going
to be sold or does he have a big 401k or
anything like that our 401 k's are
fairly equal so that'll be negligible if
there is any position i i am to take the
house and
I'm able to curate it on my own but I
have to buy him out of his portion as
well so that's another twelve thousand
dollars that will be coming once this
much is figured out okay and so there's
only just a little bit of equity in the
house
yeah only about twenty two thousand I
think they determined so why are you
telling it because it's our home you
know it's wrong cynical sighs for me and
my girls it's manageable for a much as
your house payment including insurance
750 a month what's your take home pay I
just started this division so I just
know my my growth okay what's your gross
fifty five fifty five thousand a year
yep so your take-home pay is probably
only about four thousand a little less a
month
yeah 750 is manageable that's good is
there any other and you said you finish
baby steps too so there's no other debts
no no my student loans are gone I own my
car and you'll get child support from
him yeah I'm meeting about half of what
it's supposed to be right now so right
now I get about five hundred but they
haven't I haven't received any for the
second child yet sounds like your lawyer
needs to step on this even even in the
interim if you're paying a lawyer you
should be getting child support bills I
mean that's yeah that's pretty basic
[Music]
yeah like tomorrow okay yeah you know
what you're describing is it's just
going to be tight for a little while and
you've got to give yourself a little bit
of financial margin just to grieve this
whole process and go through you know
denial anger all the different stages of
grief and the thing that you've already
been accept
inching of course 10-year marriage
coming to an abrupt in and we know it's
fairly abrupt because you have a little
baby so yeah the yeah
so I mean that just it's just there
there's emotions that go with us that
are very very real their human being
stuff and so just want to give you a
room to do all that and the big thing is
don't use all of this the babies or your
pain is an excuse to go into debt again
so don't make a mess but if you don't
make any progress I would call that a
successful transition for you okay like
no progress at all for a little while
you know get all the lawyer bills paid
court costs or whatever clean break
we're done all the checks are written
then we could push play again build up
your emergency fund and move on with the
next chapter in your life right okay the
sad thing you've already discovered and
you've discovered it because you the way
you explained things to me is what a
divorce recovery specialist it's a
friend of mine always says that a
divorce turns a marriage into a business
transaction
and so I know you've discovered that
because you've at you've already looked
through the equity you've already looked
at the differences in the 401ks or
negligible you've already done the math
on the balance sheet of the household
breaking up
you know the partnership ending it's a
transaction at this point which is very
sad but it is it is reduced to that in
the legal system so yeah you know I'm
trying to think where you're going to
get the twelve thousand bucks
how long are you going to have to get
that together well this has been going
on now for about a year it kind of
depends on there's a lot of lease and
regarding the children that has been
prolonging the entire process so this
has become way more drawn-out than
expected given I'll give you a
negotiating possibility and the fact
that he has not paid child support in
full for a year during the separation is
abominable and I think he treats that
for his equity I would love that yeah
think your attorney needs to have the
appropriate backbone to cause that to
happen see I'm just an old guy when
you're getting a fight you try to win
right yeah
yo make it like you're my daughter and
I'm trying to kill him right now
so that's I'm trying you know but I mean
he can do that he can give up the house
and due to the fact he's not paid
adequate child support for 12 months
that's a very reasonable negotiating
point otherwise I'm going back after
that money because he's you know the
longer he drags us out the longer he
does not have to pay proper child
support because you've taken a weak
position on that so that's again we're
just doing a business transaction it's
just a math thing now and we just don't
let him get away with spit two babies
involved that we're fighting for it's
not a matter of retribution or hitting
back or something like that it's it's a
matter of taking care of your children
hey thanks for the call